The second major mismatch disease like
obesity is type two diabetes and obesity.
Diabetes is also a disease of homeostasis.
Okay.
It results from obesity related.
Inflammation is regulated
by exercise and Diet.
It can be a consequence of poor
nourishment is infant or child,
and in order to understand
the homeostatic mechanism,
we begin with the normal
regulation of blood sugar.
The proximate cause of
diabetes is insulin resistance,
and that is what regulates the uptake of
blood sugar by muscle and the fat cells.
The glucose transporters in the brain
can take up glucose even when its
concentration in the blood is low.
Yeah.
Oh, the glucose transporters in liver and
pancreas only take up glucose when its
concentration in the blood is high.
Yeah.
Glucose transporters in most other tissues
respond to their functional demands,
so that privileges energy
supply to the brain. However,
only the glucose transporters in skeletal
muscle and fat respond to insulin,
which is produced when blood sugar rises
because those tissues are the
major consumers of glucose.
Insulin actually controls glucose
allocation among all tissues.
Now, in reallocation, there
are several important effects.
The first is the glucose allocation
will shift from maternal to fetal tissue
during pregnancy
and it will shift to immune
cells during infections.
So what happens here is that glucose,
insulin resistance in muscle and fat cells
so that they won't take up glucose is
allowing glucose to shift from the
maternal blood to the fetal blood during
pregnancy and from muscle and fat
into immune cells during infections.
So that is orchestrated by decreasing the
sensitivity and muscle and fat and the
capacity for insulin resistance is
built in the normal physiology and it's
essential for its functions.
So this is a good example of building,
designing a system that has in it a point
that's a weak link appointed becomes
an origin of susceptibility.
Okay,
so when does insulin
resistance become abnormal?
Obesity is causing an overflow of fatty
acids into skeletal muscle and that can
trigger insulin resistance by itself.
Okay.
Fat Tissue,
adipose tissue secrete inflammatory
cytokines that are triggering insulin
resistance directly by blocking insulin
signaling in fat, most of the lung, liver,
and it does so indirectly by blocking
lipid deposition in fat tissue,
which increases the circulation of fatty
acids that then overflow into skeletal
muscle.
So there is a dynamic loop going on
here and obesity can cause more and more
insulin resistance.
Yeah,
exercise and diet can combat it.
Exercise can prevent and reverse
insulin resistance in two ways.
It promotes the metabolism of excess
fatty acids and skeletal muscle,
so it removes that source and it activates
insulin dependent uptake of glucose
by skeletal muscle.
Yeah,
a diet rich in glucose and fructose,
however, can promote insulin resistance.
Diet and exercise alone can reverse type
two diabetes if it's caught at an early
stage and that can be more effective
than treating it with drugs.
Type two diabetes also has
developmental and genetic origins.
The risk of type two diabetes is increased
by under nourishment of the fetus
during pregnancy and have
children early in life.
Here's a child that has been starved.
Okay.
Both of those experienced stimulate
insulin resistance that can persist
throughout life.
People also very genetically
for risk of type two diabetes,
and that's mediated by environmental
effects, particularly exercise and diet.
Okay,
so type two diabetes,
like obesity is a complex
disease with multiple causes.
It's a mismatch disease caused by an
increase in insulin resistance in fat and
muscle cells.
It is,
causes include obesity
related inflammation,
lack of exercise,
a diet rich in glucose and fructose
and poor nourishment is fetus,
infant or child
type two diabetes is a disease of
homeostasis that's caused by the use of a
physiological control system that has
adjustable set points that produce
vulnerabilities that are
exploited by mismatch.
Diet and exercise alone can reverse
it if it is caught early enough.